so yeah i'm so happy to be here uh i
worked out here redefined
and we enable enterprises to design
build and operate areas that team up
with humans
and today i want to share with you what
we've learned building products that
leverage both artificial and humans
intelligence especially in ice text use
cases i want to show you what's possible
to do what are the challenges and how to
address those challenges
more importantly i want to shift your
perspective from thinking about ai as
like a monolithical end-to-end system to
think in terms of intelligence ecosystem
that mix human and
artificial intelligence
so yeah air is big it's changing the
world it's the new revolution whatever
what's important is that this revolution
shouldn't continue without taking into
account the human factor
and i don't want to talk about
machine uprising
at least not for now
but about actual concrete problems that
uh the current generation of ai has
first one is context an alignment air is
action don't align usually with human
intents because they are not aware of
context when i talk about context i want
to mention that i are narrow-minded they
don't understand why they are making
decisions they don't understand the
impact of those decisions and on the
flip side
human are usually good at that they are
good at understanding the bigger picture
to take a step back etc
and that's one of the causes of this
alignment problem
the new generation ais need to be able
to
take into account to leverage those
human skills
and to let them
supervise the ai decision or learn from
those humans decisions
second problem is that actually ais
don't really learn from collaborating
with human ai don't really know how to
collaborate to adapt to their human
co-workers
for sure we've been training ais from
annotated data for years i mean
recaptcha is exactly that we've been
training robots by proving we are not
robots since 2007 something like that
but in practice it's not collaboration
the humans is actually playing the robot
game to be able to train the robot
and even in deployed system
you can think about fulfillment center
for example we are deploying workflows
that are suited to ai systems and then
fitting humans inside those robotics
workflows
and that's
pretty much concerning in a world where
ais gets applied to a bunch of use cases
and to more and more use cases
so yeah so that's
what we believe needs to be addressed
the deployment of ai needs to be truly
beneficial to humankind so we need to be
able to address the challenges to do
that but furthermore
we need to address the challenges to
create better ai that are able to learn
from their human friends we call that
long-term objectives humanize synergy
and area-defined at its core mission
is trying to
create the condition for this human
synergy and we are doing that
by creating what i will be calling
intelligence ecosystem in this talk that
continuously learn from their experience
of shared experience of human ai
collaboration
the good news is that
the techniques to do that already exist
has been developed in academia for a
while now and
i want to show you a few examples of
those techniques and see how they can be
transposed to real-world use cases
okay so the first category of techniques
i want to talk about is what is called
behavior cloning or imitation learning
and the idea is pretty much it's pretty
simple
you have humans performing a task and
the ai is learning how to perform the
task
by reproducing by cloning the behavior
of the humans
a first early example of this kind of
techniques is alvin which is an early
autonomous driving system developed in
1988 at stanford university
and it showed interesting results i'm
sure of course it's not there yet
otherwise we would have uh autonomous
cars everywhere
um
but
it shows interesting result in this kind
of sequential decision making that are
required to do driving and that's very
different than perception tasks like the
one that we are training ai for with
something like a recaptcha
one challenge of this kind of behavior
cleaning system is that you need a lot
of data to be able to account for the
dimensionality of the sequential
decision making because basically if you
don't have enough data
the ai can get lost whenever it strays
away from the past that's been
pre-recorded before
you can
manage this kind of issues by having an
interactive system where the ai can say
hey i'm lost can you help me and the
human expert can then provide additional
information additional demonstration but
this causes additional technical
challenge
so yeah behavior cloning works you can
have fast initial training and you can
have this continuous interactive
refinement afterwards um you are quite
unsure of the alignment because
basically the ai is just reproducing
what it's so the human though
you don't require specific additional
human skills the human just need to be
able to do the job but you have bounded
performances
the ai will only able to do the job as
well as its human demonstrator
and even when you need a lot of data it
will average out and be just okay
so to address
this kind of problems
we can look at reinforcement learning
especially reinforcement learning with
human feedback
and i want to mention
works
done here at the university of texas
called tamer in 2009
and so the idea is that it's much
simpler for someone to evaluate how a
task was fulfilled than to fulfill the
task themselves so let's use this
information
i want to do quick aside on
reinforcement learning because those
methods
use reinforcement learning formalism and
it's not something that's as well known
as supervised learning so supervised
learning we all know what it is it's
basically providing examples of how to
do a task and let the human learn from
those examples
reinforcement learning is objective
driven
you tell a task what's the objective
using some kind of function
and the ai will learn by trial and error
to
find a good way to fulfill this
objective
that's how deepmind researchers were
able to beat
a lot of the atari games a few years ago
um
the the reward function being the score
of the atari game
so this trial and error um causes
different kind of challenges the first
one is that you need a safe environment
to do that you can't do trial and error
in the real world most of the time
because you might end up in dangerous
situations
and you need to have a safe environment
which are basically simulations that are
quite fast because usually you need to
accumulate years and years of experience
for an ai to be able to do something
useful
the second set of challenges is this
reward function
usually in real-world tasks the reward
is not as easy as using the score from
an entire game
so to address those challenges
we can use humans
so let's go back to tamer and its
successors
so on the right hand side you can see a
method called deeptamer that was used to
basically create agents that are better
uh than at atari games than the one
train without human input you can see
here the blue curve which is the agent
learning you can see that in 10 minutes
it gets better than the average level of
its evaluator
at the game so they managed training
either better than them and in 15
minutes the ai gets better than the best
human at this game
and you can see also that on the bottom
you have the regular reinforcement
learning method and
deep tumor is learning much faster it's
learning much faster because it can
learn from the expertise of the humans
in this game
the other example is coach
coach is the same kind of algorithm but
in the real world
and they are training robots to do fetch
tasks in a few minutes by giving them
feedback so yeah this approach
enables superhuman or even optimal
performances
you still have control over the
alignment the human can provide
really rich information in the reward
and can
basically reward
an agent that's that's doing what the
human intent the the ai to do
it requires some specialized skill you
need to understand how the eye learns to
be able to give good rewards
and one thing that's a little touchy to
do technically is that the
when you have a reward function the the
reward arrives
instantaneously
during the training process when you
have a human acting as a reward function
the reward can be delayed and you need
the full system to take that into
account to be able to train properly
and last but not least it requires a
safe environment which is basically
usually a simulation
building upon those two kind of seminal
work uh see something that we've done at
air redefine uh that's a little mix of
both that is akin to dual control at
driving school when you have like a
monitor that is able to take over from
the students
um and the idea here is to use human
demonstration but not to use them as
reference but to use them as a way to
explore the world in
in an easier way
so that's a
typical reinforcement learning benchmark
here where you are
trying to land a spaceship between the
two poles
and whenever there is a red outline it's
because the human is taking over from
from from the eye so interactively
trains the ai to perform the task
but the eye is not using this
demonstration as a reference it's using
those demonstrations as a way to
provide further information about
what actions leads to what
in terms of results it's interesting
so the blue line is the traditional
reinforcement learning method after a
while they cross this horizontal
threshold which means that they manage
to
land consistently and then gets better
which means they land faster and faster
in our case uh we have a first part
which is the red line which is the
performances of the team the ai plus
human team at the task
so basically right away it manages to
land consistently and it would be even
better if the demonstrator which is me
in this case would be better at the task
what's interesting if you transpose that
to a real world scenario is that what it
means is that the team can be deployed
right away
the team can be fulfilling the task of
course the human will do more most of
the work but then gradually the ai will
be able to take over
and that's the orange part of the curve
even when the human stops interacting
with the ai the ai is constantly better
at the task than an ai that didn't
benefit from this human expertise
that's
an approach that we call ai
apprenticeship
where basically you have a mentor
and an ai
student that learns on the job
what's interesting about this approach
is that the training goes both way
the ai is learning from the human
expertise but the human is also learning
to trust the ai to understand how the ai
is performing the task where it is good
it is bad
so yeah with this kind of method still
you get superior man or even optimal
performances you have still control
about the alignment of the behavior of
the ai you don't really require
additional human skills the human just
performed their job
but there is a
an emphasis to to to have on the ux part
where you need a
interface an interactive setup where the
operationally the human can perform his
job while training the ai and you need
to do that during a training phase but
also during operations to benefit from
this ai apprentice approach
before switching gear to
actual industrial use case uh i want to
mention this work so this is work by
openai that was done in 2020 and 2021 on
summarization so basically taking a text
and generating a summary
the approach that they have taken is uh
let's pre-train a language model a
gpt-style large language model over the
internet and then use
human interaction to fine-tune this
model to create better summaries
so they are using
humans both as demonstrators that
provide reference summaries and also as
evaluators that
give preference between variation of
summaries
so you can see the results are on the
right side
um
the orange curve is the human feedback
method that shows that
the generated summaries are preferred by
human panel
interesting learning from this work the
first big interesting learning is this
ability to fine-tune something that has
been learned traditionally
learning with a human in the loop is
costly because you need to have the
human in the loop so it's important to
do the most of the work
without the human and then
target where you use the human manpower
they show that it works even on large
models
they are using hybrid technique it's not
just about using demonstration or
feedback it's using both
and contrary to the other tasks that
were more toy examples
this is
on a language task that's something much
closer to what the industry is actually
using
and the last but not least
this method is about improving alignment
so they've shown that by using human
they're able to provide
summaries that are more aligned to the
human expectation than previously
okay
um so the first
real world example i want to share with
you is a domain that's called
man-machine teaming in the aerospace and
defense industry
and man-machine teaming in this industry
is seen as kind of an objective
they realize that
they will need to create
machines and ais that fulfill complex
tasks but they also need to keep humans
in the loop because of the high stakes
of the decision that they are making
they need the accountability and they
need the sensibility of the human so
they are developing techniques for this
teaming to work and to be efficient
this is an early example of the work
that we are doing with the company
called tales who is a leader in the
aerospace and defense industry
and their goal is to create a platform
to train and operate fleets of drones
that can collaborate with human pilots
and so in this example
you have autonomous drones that are
scouting uh terrain a forest for fires
and uh you have a human pilot uh a human
pilot in a helicopter that's there to go
from fire to fire and extinguish those
fires so the two needs to collaborate
for uh to to efficiently
extinguish the fires
the way
this was implemented in this in this
experimental platform is
as a
training application for human pilots
so the idea is to train helicopter
pilots to better collaborate with the
drones they can
they learn how to use the information
provided by the drones and they learn
they also learn how to give orders to
the drone
when they want to have specific
information about a part of the terrain
and in fact
all the signals that are provided by the
humans
are used implicitly to train the drones
themselves so in practice it's a
platform that's training the team of
human and aia drones
and having implicit
signals means that
we remove part of the bias
in the training process because the
humans are just performing their job
they they are not trying to make the ai
do something
um that's the first benefit of this kind
of approach
the second one is you are not wasting
time basically you are training the
humans alongside the eye it's not
dedicated time of the humans to do
something it's they need to train
for sure for that kind of thing to work
you can't
you can start you can't start ais that
are just completely dumb uh randomly
exploring reinforcement learning agent
you need to have pre-trained those ai um
you have basically two ways of doing
that
um
either you start with a
reactive doctrinal behavior so
heuristics based behavior for those ai
and you train on the side new version of
the drones and then when they are ready
you deploy everything
or you can pre-train in the same setup
by replacing the human with
an ai system that will train
those drones to to get the basics
and last but not least this kind of
system enables real-time human
supervision and enables the agent to
train to understand this human
supervision so here the human can give
orders to the drone we have worked since
then in examples where the drones have
some actions that requires
pre-authorization from the human to be
able to be performed
and those kind of setups means that the
drones not only need to know which
action that they would
ask the human for
but also to to teach the drone to
anticipate the time it will take for the
human to accept or refuse an action
so in in the previous example we already
had some kind of heterogeneous
collaboration because the drones and the
the helicopter had different uh ways to
interact with the environment
um and to go beyond that we've developed
this concept of intelligence ecosystem
in in this example it's really pushed a
little more
so this is something that we've
developed with the city of hong kong
and more importantly with the emergency
dispatcher of the city of kung so
basically the people who answer 911
calls and then decide to dispatch an
ambulance or auto truck or a firefighter
vehicle to an emergency
and so those guys um
they can be overwhelmed by the number of
emergencies they have to deal with
and so they would like to have ai
assistance to help them even the
workload
to help them even their cognitive load
but on the flip side they are making
really high-tech decisions and so um
they
the the the the need the humans to be
kept in the loop of those decisions and
to
provide accountability for those
decisions
so the way that we've been approaching
this collaboration is by developing a
dynamic assistance ai that gets out of
the way when everything is fine and that
have more autonomy and helps on some of
the tasks that the human are doing when
it's in crisis mode
so you can see here the
the prototype ui that was developed
basically the human received emergency
the each emergency is get a
recommendation dispatch from an ai
system that the human can
edit
fully accept or partially accept or
completely reject
and
and then dispatch
and uh the eye can also make free
autonomous decisions that the ai can
then after the fact
a review
under the hood it works like a
multi-agent system we have in fact
different kinds of agent
the one that deals with the routing of
the unit the one that deals with the
dispatch of the unit the evaluation of
the priority of those emergency the
evaluation of the autonomy level that
can be taken by the ai so whether or not
it should take fully autonomous action
or just the recommendation and the role
taken by the human here which is
basically accepting or rejecting
recommendation
and
in terms of projects we started by
developing a very first simple version
of those agents with basic heuristics
which meant that we were able to deploy
something really quickly
and
because it was very quickly were able to
first get insight about how the system
was used by the operators but also get
data
and um and start training agents on
those different uh on those different
roles
while having a baseline of the
performances
and in the end we actually replaced uh
at this stage when we replaced two of
the agents the first one uh which is a
dispatch one was replaced with a
constraint solver so nothing to do with
machine learning and the second one
which is the autonomy level
deciding whether or not to take a fully
autonomous action
was replaced with a reinforcement
learning-based agent
but
this kind of modular approach
paid dividends because of
this kind of gradual
deployment and the ability to generate
data from day one basically so yeah
faster deployment and faster iteration
this ability to have several roles some
of them that can be taken by humans some
of them that can be fully autonomous
enables different degrees of supervision
based on the needs that you have
and the fact that you have smaller
footprints agent means that you can
more easily
do compliance check decide to do some
part that as fully explainable agent etc
and so beyond those obvious use case
where humans lives are at stake there's
a bunch of other verticals where humans
actually are doing most of the job today
and would benefit from ai that can
collaborate with them so i've listed a
few here we are currently working a lot
in utilities and education but uh
transportation especially autonomous
driving at higher level of autonomy
is something that makes sense else for
sure makes sense
so let's
kind of
recap the benefits that i've
talked about the first one is this
ability to leverage human expertise
it's important to be able to train
better ai that are able to understand
more things in the context that are able
to train quickly
because of
the usage of human expertise but it's
also
level this human expertise at operation
time and
be able to to
to mix between a fully
supervised system and fully autonomous
system
and foster collaboration
second benefit is this ability to deploy
faster and continuously
the idea of having
smaller footprint agent that you can
develop first version of quite easily
makes it easy to deploy something
quickly the idea of ai apprenticeship
makes it easy to have something that
will grow gradually and be more and more
autonomous
and last but not least this idea of
trust
when you
are putting in the hand of the same
humans that will have them as co-workers
ai system from from their inception you
are building these thrust relationships
you are building um the humans are
building a mental model of all the ai
systems react behave
and as
because of that they're able to trust
them more
of course it means a bunch of uh
challenges technical challenges the
first one is continuous learning and
it's really important to to to have that
in mind
you can't have this kind of gradually
deploying system if you have a
traditional pipeline which will be
trained validate deploy you need to have
a continuous update of the training
model you need to have online learning
you need to mix and match multiple ai
techniques not only machine learning
technique but also playing all the ai
and you need to be pragmatic about that
to be able to capture the most of those
human signals that you can
and last but not least you need to be
tech agnostic
we are talking about having a tight
integration between ai systems uh
between simulations
if you want to do this kind of of
pre-training
between data pipeline of data ingress
and also egress to real-world system
between ux systems and so you need to
orchestrate between all of those in real
time to provide online learning things
and it's not only different text it's
also different culture and different
engineering approaches
so yeah of course
that's why we built a cognitive segment
is our open source platform it's there
to build training operator agents in
those kind of shared environment and
it's designed to help those different
engineering cultures to collaborate with
each other and the different tech stacks
to collaborate with each other
it's enabled this ability to continue to
train air and humans together to operate
those intelligence ecosystem and it's
designed to move from a simulated world
a fully simulated world to a fully real
world with the same setup and with the
same orchestration platform it's
available as an open source
platform we are already being used by a
bunch of research lab at this stage and
we are providing as a company commercial
offering on top
of
of the open source platform
in the in the areas i was mentioning
before
so yeah what i want you to
take away from this talk
the first thing is that when you are
designing ai enabled products in fact
you are not designing air enabled
products you are designing human ai
relationship
and it's a ux problem for sure it's a
design problem but it's also an ai
problem and it's also important to
consider the different kind of ai
techniques that you can leverage to
facilitate this collaboration
the ai apprentice approach is something
that's really
that really we believe in and that will
facilitate the deployment the early
deployment of this kind of techniques
most of those ai training techniques are
quite advanced we are not
some of them are not really ready for
prime time so having something that can
be gradually learning that can have
different level of supervision helps
with testing right now those techniques
and last but not least this this idea of
thinking in terms of intelligence
ecosystem
in terms of distributed decision making
that involves both artificial
intelligence and human intelligence
will
will make you designs simpler
and
more
effective systems
that can benefit from future and better
techniques
thank you
that's us we are hiring we are in
montreal it's very cool
and i will take questions now
[Applause]
you